Okay.
Uh,
we're talking about the origin
and fate of the universe. And, uh,
let me remind you of the story so far.
Uh,
yeah.
Um,
and they're basically two sets of
observations that are important here.
One is,
uh,
the existence of the Hubble diagram,
and Hubble's law,
which is the observational relationship
between distance and velocity for
galaxies.
Uh,
and this leads you to the
idea of a universal expansion.
And the other is what
we discussed last time,
his time, uh, that, um,
if you look back into the
past, if you observe, uh, with,
uh, a large, at a large distance,
that is to say a large look back time.
Okay.
Uh, what you discover is, uh, that
things were different in the past.
Yeah.
The universe as a whole,
uh, look somewhat, uh,
somewhat different and in
particular, uh, was, uh,
significantly denser, which is
exactly what you would predict if a,
the universe was expanding.
And these two things,
these two observational facts
put together are really, uh,
what lead to,
uh,
the idea of a universe
with a big bang cosmology.
And this is great,
uh,
because you can then use this assumption
that everything is governed by this
scale factor of the universe
and the scale factor starts, uh,
either at zero or very close to
zero and gets bigger with time.
And you could use that concept to
do all sorts of wonderful things.
You can describe the past.
Uh,
and in particular,
uh,
one of the things we did last time was to
calculate the age of the universe from,
from the observations of the Hubble
constant. And you can predict the future
and the future depends on,
uh,
how the expansion of the
scale factor changes.
If the scale factor just continues
to expand at its current rate,
the universe will continue to expand,
uh,
and gradually get sparser and sparser
and colder and colder and more and more
boring.
Uh,
but it's not expected that the scale
that the expansion rate stays the same.
It's expected that the expansion
rate will change. And in particular,
it's expected that the expansion
rate will slow down. Why?
Because there's matter in
the universe and matter, uh,
exerts gravity and gravity tends
to pull things back together again.
And so this is where we
ended up, uh, last time. Uh,
if you assume that gravity
is the dominant force,
that is to say that any changes in the
expansion rate of the universe will be
due to gravity,
then you can derive this critical
density can we did last time,
which is a quantity equal to three h
squared over eight Pi g h you measure the
other things are just constant and you
can calculate what this quantity is.
Now at this point,
let me write down a piece
of astronomical jargon,
which I didn't do last
time. Uh, it, the dance,
the actual density of the universe
divided by this critical density,
uh, is given a letter of
its own. This is give,
this is written down as a capitol Omega.
So Omega is uh, the true, ah, the
actual density of the universe,
whatever that turns out to be
divided by the critical density.
And then you can describe the future of
the universe depending on what Omega is.
If Omega is greater than one,
that means that the density is
greater than the critical density. Uh,
and this leads to re collapse.
And the big crutch.
Whereas if Omega is less than one,
uh,
the universe expands forever.
Somebody asked what happens if
Omega is exactly equal to one? Uh,
in that case, there's no big crunch.
The universe expands forever,
but the expansion rate, ask them
topically approaches zero. Uh,
but of course in real life it's very hard
to get something that's exactly some,
any physical quantity to be precisely
equal to any theoretical value.
Um, and so with this in mind, uh,
if then becomes very important to
actually go out and measure the average
density of the universe, uh, because uh,
then you could divide it by this critical,
uh,
density.
We've already measured h so we know
what this quantity is and then you could
figure out what's going to happen.
So the goal here is to determine,
uh,
the density of the universe.
And conceptually,
this isn't such a hard thing to do.
You go out and measure mass of
everything. You can see, uh,
you try and do it over a large volume
because what you want to avoid,
the mistake you want to
avoid is to, uh, measure, uh,
the density of a piece of the universe
that doesn't represent the overall
average. If we measured the density
of material in this room, uh,
it would be,
uh,
something like 27 orders of magnitude
bigger than the critical density.
And if we assumed that the universe,
we're just like this room,
obviously it would, we collapse. In fact,
it would have recollapsed long ago. Uh,
but, uh, we don't do that because
of course most of the universities,
not like this room, most of the
universities empty. So you say, well,
we better include a lot of stars,
uh, and the empty spaces between the,
but even that's a mistake because you're
measuring stars in our own galaxy.
So you say,
well,
we better include lots of galaxies and
the empty space spaces between them.
Uh, that still doesn't work for a while
because there are clusters of galaxies,
there are clusters of clusters
of galaxies. And so, uh,
you have to go really quite far out
before you have a fair sample of what the
average conditions in the university,
like buddy a principal.
That's certainly possible to do.
You just keep measuring things further
and further and further away until you
get to a point where if
you increase the distance,
where as you increase the distance,
that density doesn't change anymore.
So you're out to the park, uh, where
you've really achieved the average.
How do you know you've achieved the
average when you look out twice as far and
you get the same answer. Uh,
and so, uh, in principle,
the way you do this is
you add up all the mass,
uh, in some, uh,
a sizable chunk of the
universe in a sufficiently
large chunk of the universe.
Yeah.
Were sufficiently largest,
sufficiently large to average over,
uh, uh, any local perturbations. Uh,
so you add up all the math
and you divide by the volume,
you divide by the volume that
that, uh, uh, mass occupies.
And so obviously you have to identify all
the different kinds of mass. Uh, and uh,
you have to make sure that
whatever volume you've taken,
you found all the mass in it. You add
it all up, you divide by volume, uh,
you determine that gives
you a value for density.
You divide by the critical density and
you know what's going to happen, uh,
to the universe. Okay. Uh,
now how do you find the mass of things
determining mass?
Well,
one way you could do it is you can
just go out and measure how bright yes,
go ahead.
Oh,
put this back for a second.
Top Park.
Bottom part. What do you, yeah.
Yeah.
So you determine the density of the
universe by adding up the mass divided by
the volume. Uh, and then the question
becomes how do you determine the mass?
Uh,
and uh, one way you can
do it is you, uh, uh,
you look at how bright
things are and up the light.
You see,
and then you assume,
uh,
some value for the amount
of mass it takes to, uh,
create a certain amount of lice light.
So that's assuming what's
called a mass to light ratio.
Uh, and so you can do that.
You know, if it's the sun,
then one solar mass produces one
solar luminosity. If all stars,
if all objects are exactly like the sun,
then everything would be like that.
It turns out that isn't the case.
Uh,
but you can take local samples of stars
and figure out what the average last
delight ratio is.
A.
And if you have some value that you're
happy with of mass delight ratio,
then you multiply the amount of
light by the mass to like ratio.
And this gives you a mass,
uh,
sorry.
Uh, well, what do you mean by light? Is
the, do you need to adjust for distance?
Uh, what you mean by light
is the intrinsic light.
You mean the equivalent
of the absolute magnitude,
which takes the distance into account.
So what you need to ask is not
how bright it looks. Uh, but, uh,
it's intrinsic brightness in this
particular case. Yes. So you do,
you do need to account for the distance.
And so you need to be thinking about
absolute magnitude rather than apparent
magnitude. Yes. Uh, but,
and that's one of the problems that's
hard to do. The other problem of course,
is this awkward word here,
uh,
which is the kind of thing that makes
people nervous because you could get that
wrong if you're looking at a one kind of
star and it's actually some other kind
of Starwood, which happens to be
much more massive but dimmer, uh,
like a white dwarfs or something
like that, then you're going to,
then you're going to make a mess of this.
So there's an alternative method, uh,
which you may already have considered
because we've done it in both of the
previous parts of this class,
which is, uh, you measure
orbits
and you do the same thing we did with
in part one and part two of the class.
You find some star in the distant
portion of a galaxy orbiting around the
galaxy. You're figuring out
how fast the thing is going.
You figure out how far the thing
is going, use Kepler's laws, uh,
and you, uh, determine, uh, the mass
from orbital theory,
from Kepler's laws basically.
And in particular,
you know,
v squared is equal to g m over a.
And so you can measure this
from the doppler shift. Uh,
you can determine this. Uh,
basically in the case of galaxies,
galaxies are big objects. You can
physically measure, uh, the, uh,
angular separation on the guide.
Use the small angle formula if you
know the distance to determine this.
So this can also be measured, uh,
and therefore this can be calculated.
Okay.
And so you go and do that for a whole
bunch of galaxies and this has been done.
And let me,
let me give you some examples here.
Let me actually write down some numbers
and do and do some calculations.
Supposing you have a galaxy,
a add a distance of
20 mega parsecs,
uh,
and supposing it has an apparent magnitude
of something like 14.
Yeah.
These are kind of typical numbers for,
uh,
galaxies in a nearby galaxy. Clusters
in printed, there's a particular,
the nearest big galaxy cluster to to
us is a cluster in the constellation of
Virgo,
known as the Virgo cluster.
If you want to know about the Virgo
cluster asks you crowd who is devoting his
life to the study of this object,
uh, and the galaxies within it.
But these are sort of quasi
typical numbers, uh, uh,
adjusted slightly because
it's actually 17 mega parsec.
She's just kind of a pain.
Uh, all right. So, uh,
what do you know about the mass?
What can you determine about the
mass of such and such a galaxy?
Well, Oh, and let me warn you before we
even begin to, of course, astronomers,
it played you a dirty trick,
namely that the symbol we
use for magnitude is m a,
the symbol we use for mass is also an a.
So you've got to keep those clear
in your mind. Uh, all right.
So what do we know
about this? We know, uh,
the relationship between a parent
and absolute magnitude. Naza,
I said just a minute ago.
It's the absolute magnitude that
we need to know in order to, uh,
actually determine anything.
M minus M is equal to five log d over 10.
Parsecs. So, uh, let's figure
out the right hand side first.
That's five blog. Uh, two
times 10 to the seven.
That's 20 mega parsecs, one
mega parsecs 10 to the six, uh,
over 10. That's five log, uh,
two times 10 to six. Now what
do I do about that? Let's see,
that's a five times log of 10 to the six.
That's pretty
straightforward. Uh, plus, uh,
the log of two because uh, uh,
if you add logs, then you multiply
the thing inside the parentheses.
So log of two plus log of 10 to the six
is equal to log of two times 10 to the
six block of 10 to the six is six,
log of two is 0.3.
It's just a useful number to know.
Uh,
the log of two is around 0.3.
The lag of three is around 0.5.
The log of five is around 0.7.
Uh, you could look it up. Uh,
and so this is equal to five times 6.3,
five times six is 35 times
0.3 is one and a half.
So this is 31.5.
Uh,
let me caution you at this point.
so let me give you a
little side note here. Uh,
do not approximate
magnitudes.
Why not?
I mean,
we approximate everything else in this
course magnitudes are a logarithmic
quantity, right? Uh,
and so you don't approximate magnitude
for the same reason that you don't,
uh, that you're don't
approximate the exponent.
You can't say 10 to the seven
is equal to 10 to the six.
You can say seven equals six,
but you can't say 10 to the seven is
equal to 10 to the six because uh,
that's a factor of 10 difference.
Where's the difference between seven and
six is, is just a little more than 10%.
Similarly, this 0.3, uh,
you would have been tempted to get rid of
it, right? Because who cares about, uh,
about the difference between six and 6.3,
but in fact it comes
out of this log of two.
And so 0.3 in the log is
actually a factor of two.
Uh, and so you gotta, you
gotta not approximate the
exponent. This is important.
Yes. We should also try to be more
precise when we're dealing with attitudes.
Well, yes, that's thing, I guess
that's saying the same thing.
Should you be more precise? That means you
shouldn't approximate. Yeah. So I guess,
uh, uh, uh, but um, uh, but it's,
it's, it's for the same reason that
you don't approximate the exponent. Uh,
and it's also true that uh,
the numbers are easier to work with
because it turns out that you add the
brother the multiplying the most of
the time, so it's not such a bad thing.
Anyway, here we are at
31.5. Uh, so what do we got?
We've got,
uh,
m minus M is equal to 31.5.
This M was stated in the problem to be 14.
Uh,
so 14 minus 31.5 equals m.
so m is equal to minus 17 and a half.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, that's not such a bad
number. We can work with that.
Uh, now what are we, so now we
know the absolute magnitude.
We know how bright the thing is.
So now we can figure out how many
times brighter than the sun it is.
Why is that a useful thing?
Because if you then make the assumption
that the mass to like ratio is the same
as the sun, that this galaxy
consists entirely of sunlight stars,
then you can determine how massive
it is. So let's do that. Uh,
how many sons?
Uh,
and this is the other magnitude
equation. This is a, you know,
m one minus m two is equal to,
uh,
for two different objects is equal to
minus five halves log of the brightness of
one over the brightness
of the other. Uh, and now,
but I think I wanted in the other form,
I think I wanted in the form 10 to the
minus oh 0.4 or 10 to the minus two
fifths,
a m one minus m two is
equal to B one over B two.
This is the exact same equation as
you'll recall. Uh, just, uh, uh,
having been getting rid of the log,
taking everything, taking everything,
putting it on to the 10 to
the something power. Uh,
the reason I wanted in this form
is that this is the answer I want.
I want be one. [inaudible].
I want one to be the galaxy.
I want to to be the son.
So then I've got 10 to
the minus two fifths,
and then the galaxy is minus 17 and a
half. That's the absolute magnitude.
Uh,
the sun is minus the son is five,
has an absolute magnitude of five,
and that's going to give me the brightness
of the galaxy over the brightness of
the sun.
Uh,
that's 10 to the minus two
fifths of 22 and a half.
Uh, let's see the minuses cancel
out. So that's a plus. Actually.
Two fifths times 20, two
and a half. Well, let's see.
Two Times 22 and a half is 45.
A fifth of 45 is nine.
So this is equal to 10 to the nine.
So this galaxy is a billion
times brighter than the sun,
10 to the nine times brighter
than the sun. So, uh,
if it were made out of sunlight stars,
it would have a mass of a
billion solar masses. So mass,
uh, would equal 10 to the
nine times the mass of the sun
if all sunlight
stars.
But it turns out that galaxies
to be somewhat dimmer than
the sun per unit mass.
Uh, most stars are a little
bit less massive than the sun,
but a lot less bright. Uh, this is
just the way stars' turn out to be a.
And so typical mass delight ratios of,
of populations of stars tend to be on
the order of 10 or something like that,
times the Sun. So, uh,
probably it needs to be more massive
cause typical stars are
fainter than the sun.
Typically
stars are fainter.
Okay.
Ah, so you could guess
and say mass maybe should
B,
I dunno, 10 times greater than
that, 10 to the 10 solar masses.
And you could see why this
particular line of reasoning, uh,
starts to get pretty dubious because that
I picked this number completely out of
the air. Uh, there's actually
some modest basis for it,
but you could pick other numbers. Uh,
you could argue about this endlessly. Uh,
and you wouldn't get very far.
Why should it be 10 times the Sun?
Maybe it's a hundred, maybe
it's a thousand. Maybe
it's less than the sun. Uh,
how would you really know?
Uh,
and so let's go back and
do the other approach,
namely, uh, figure out, uh,
it's mass from orbits of things around it.
So let's look at it.
The supposing it's an edge on galaxy.
Here's the center of the Galaxy, uh,
or, and uh, actually let's
look at it from the top.
So here is a nice spiral
galaxy of some kind.
Here's the center of the spiral galaxy.
Here's some star way out on the edge.
Uh, that star is moving around the
center of the galaxy. It has to be,
or it's going to fall in. So it's
orbiting around the center of the Galaxy,
presumably in some circular orbit.
Your down here looking at this thing,
and of course you can measure the
velocity of that star by the doppler shift
because it's moving away from you.
Uh,
and so one can measure this velocity.
you can measure this distance,
uh,
that would be the equivalent of a in
our formulas because it's the distance
between the orbiting
object and the center, uh,
stars are much less massive than galaxies.
So we don't have to worry
about the motion of the galaxy.
And you can use a familiar
equation, namely, uh,
v squared equals g m over a.
So now let's give this some numbers.
Uh,
typical velocities of things orbiting
around the galaxy turned out to be
something like 200 kilometers a second
or two times 10 to the five meters per
second. Uh, and, uh, the size
of a typical galaxy, you know,
out to where it stops being
easy to see stars is, oh,
I don't know what number did I take here?
Uh,
doop doop,
yeah,
let's call it 20 kiloparsecs,
which is two times 10 to the four.
Uh,
parsecs and a parsec is three
times 10 to the 16 meters.
So this is six times 10 to the 20 meters.
So now let's calculate amp
n Equals v squared,
a over g,
uh,
two times 10 to the five squared,
six times 10 to the 20th,
uh,
over seven times 10 to the minus 11.
Get rid of those.
Uh,
let's see,
that's four times
10 to the 30,
over 10 to the minus 11,
four times 10 to the 41.
This isn't kilograms,
okay?
One solar mass,
You'll recall is two times 10 to the 30.
So this mass
in units of the Sun,
four times 10 to the 41
over two times 10 to the 30,
which is something like two
times 10 to the 11 solar masses.
And now we have a problem, right? You,
you probably don't remember what the
answer to the previous version of this
problem was,
where we did it with light that
came out to a magnitude of,
uh,
uh, the brightness was about
10 to the nine times the sun.
Maybe the mass is 10 to
the 10 times the Sun.
But now we've just calculated it
in this other more reliable way.
And it's two times 10 to the 11.
It's 20 times more massive
than you thought it was going
to be. Given how bright,
uh, how bright the light from
this thing was. Yes. Question.
This is the massive, the galaxy. Yes.
Okay.
Now before I go on,
let me just point out those of you who
have taken a look at the problem set,
what I've just done here, this
calculation I've just done is problem.
One of the problem set except done
backwards, uh, in on the problem set,
what I did is I told you what the Mat,
what the density was,
what the critical density
was, and then, uh,
you had to derive characteristics
of the galaxy from that.
Here I've told you what the galaxies are
like. Uh, we figured out, uh, how big,
uh, how massive they are. Uh,
if we divide by the volume, uh,
we'll get a density. So we're doing the
same problem backwards, I should say.
The numbers I've chosen
here are different.
So you can't know the answer to the
problem set by looking at the premises of
these particular things. But the, uh, uh,
what I'm doing is the exact same set of
calculations, only done a done backwards.
Uh, so, uh, that may
or may not be helpful,
but let's pause here for a
moment because this is now
we're now up to,
we're making progress.
We're now up to frontiers
and controversies circa 1985.
You remember in 1920,
they were worried about whether the
spiral nebulae we're actually galaxies in
1950. They were worried about maybe the
steady state was the correct response.
And by the time 1985 rolls around,
the big issue is okay.
Uh,
uh hmm.
Mass is determined by orbital rotation.
Uh,
so what's your Mike called?
Dynamical masses.
That is to say determined
bye
orbits of things around galaxies,
orbits around galaxies.
And also I should take galaxy clusters.
Uh,
you can have galaxies orbiting around
each other and, and galaxies, uh,
orbiting around whole clusters of galaxies
in the same thing is true and Gal.
So around galaxies and galaxy clusters,
uh,
are much bigger
then you expect from the light.
They give off and therefore, uh,
by a thought,
a factor of 10 by
approximately a factor of 10.
So there's 10 times more mass than you
can account for by adding up all the
stars. Now there's mass in other
forms of that stars. There's also a,
um, uh, there's also
dust. There's also gas.
These are things you can detect in other
ways. You add them all up, uh, and,
uh,
you're still off by about a factor of 10,
so there's 10 times more bass than
you have any way of accounting for it.
This is the so called dark matter problem.
So this is Ron tears in
controversies in 1985. Uh,
there's all this dark matter.
Most of the matter in galaxies is
in some form that we can't detect.
It's dark matter.
And what is it
now, unlike frontiers in
controversies in 1920 and 1950,
this is one that we haven't solved
yet. So I don't know the answer. Uh,
for a quarter of a century, people have
been busily trying to figure this out. Uh,
there's still no good answer. And 10
years ago when I taught this course, uh,
what this question of what is the dark
matter was a big focus of this part of
the course. And now I'm
going to, uh, uh, uh,
talk about it only in, in this
class, only in one lecture,
because we got way bigger problems either
than this, uh, that's saying a lot. Uh,
I've just told you that we don't know
what 90% of the mass in the universe is,
and then we've got bigger problems
than that. Uh, so, uh, it's, uh,
things are getting a little murky here,
uh,
and not just because the
matter is dark. Um, okay.
So what,
let's all,
but let me pause a little bit on dark
matter cause it's an interesting problem.
Uh, and what, uh, W as I say, we
have no idea what this stuff is.
What are the possibilities?
So here's a hypothesis.
Uh,
hypothesis number one is
that what this stuff is is,
uh,
some,
yeah,
kind of unknown.
A subatomic particle.
Yeah.
Uh,
and it has to have two characteristics.
This subatomic particle for it to
work out, it has to have mass. Uh,
that's pretty basic. If you're using it
to explain that you can't have photons,
right? Oh, Todd's don't carry any
mass. Uh, it has to have mass,
but it has to, uh, not
interact with light,
no interaction
with
like
if it absorbs light,
it would be opaque and we would know it
was there because galaxies behind this
stuff would look dim. A alternatively,
if it gives off light, uh,
then we'd see it. Uh, and so, uh, it,
it has to not interact with light or
interact with light only very weekly. Uh,
and so these are given
the name, uh, generically,
weekly interactive,
inter active,
massive.
Yeah,
particles
or whips.
So here's the hypothesis. The
Universe is 90% wimps. Uh,
this is not such a crazy idea as it,
that might at first seem there are known
subatomic particles that have these
properties.
There's something called the Neutrino.
There are trillions of them going
through this room every second. Uh,
they have mass, uh, and they don't
interact very much with anything.
They are known to exist from particle
or a particle accelerator experiment.
And they have been detected from
celestial sources. Now we know that the,
for various reasons that the dark matter
doesn't consist of neutrinos, uh, uh,
but there could be many
other kinds of particles, uh,
with these kinds of characteristics.
And indeed, some are predicted, uh,
by carp particle theories. Uh, as
I say, wimps, it been detected.
The SNORRI wimps have not been detected,
but neutrinos have been detected.
Here's how they do it. It's kind
of an amazing experiment. Uh,
they took a mine shaft and in South
Dakota and filled it with cleaning fluid.
And the reason they did that
was that every so often, uh,
neutrinos don't interact with,
with light,
but they do interact
occasionally with chlorine atoms.
And the effect of a neutrino banging
into a chlorine atom is to turn it into
Argon. Uh, and so this
happens a there, as I say,
trillions of neutrinos flow through this
mine every second, once a day or so,
one of them will hit a chlorine atom.
Just write, create an Argon, Adam.
So here's what you do. You fill
your mind shaft with cleaning fluid,
a large fraction of which is chlorine.
Uh,
and to count the Argon atoms
that bubble off the top. Uh,
and this has been successful. Uh, they
detected neutrinos emitted from the sun.
The Sun is all stars
that, that have, uh, uh,
nuclear reactions going on in the emit
neutrinos as part of the output of these
nuclear reactions.
And then they had a problem because they
had predicted how many neutrinos you
ought to see from the sun and
an experiment of this kind.
And they didn't see enough of them.
They only saw a third of them.
And it turns out. And then there was a
big debate for a long time. This is is,
so this is frontiers and controversies
circa about 1975 a there was a big debate
for a while.
Where are all the solar neutrinos?
Is it possible that we don't understand
nuclear reactions in the sun?
Is it possible that we don't
understand the chemistry of our,
of chlorine or Argon? After all?
You're counting individual argon atoms.
So that's a kind of a difficult test.
A No,
it turned out that what was going on
was we didn't understand neutrinos.
And it turns out there are three kinds
of neutrinos and neutrinos a switch back
and forth between these different kinds,
and you could only detect one kind of
by the chlorine. And so you only did to,
and,
and so they were all emitted from the sun
as if they were the kind you could, uh,
in the form that you would
have been able to detect them.
But as they traveled from the sun
to us, uh, some fraction of them,
a flip back and forth between all
these other, other kinds of new,
I ended up only with
about a third of them.
So it was a big piece of particle
physics. It was discovered. Uh,
we have also detected by now,
uh,
neutrinos coming from
supernova explosion. So, uh,
there 2011 of them,
I think were detected all at once.
And if you're detecting
things sort of once per day,
and then you suddenly detect 11 of them
over the course of a few minutes, uh,
you've seen something exciting
occur. And that was, uh,
a no is now known to be this,
this supernova explosion that occurred
in a neighboring galaxy. Uh, and,
uh, so there are a bunch
of, so by analogy with that,
people are looking for the whips that
make up the dark matter. If it turns,
if all this dark matters in Wimps,
there are lots and lots and lots of
these things and they're going through us
every second.
So there are a whole bunch of experiments
with the same basic characteristics.
You have a huge vat of something
and something is supposed to happen
occasionally when one of these wimps
hits whatever's in the VAT. Uh,
so the Japanese have, uh, uh,
sort of a cubic mile of distilled water
and they're looking for little light
flashes when the Neutrino runs into
the watermark and they busted all their
detectors.
Recently they had a sort of earthquake
and it was bad for the little light
detectors they had put on
the inside of these things.
But there are a lot of such a experiment.
Dan Mckinsey here in the
physics department is a, is
a big player in one of them.
Uh,
and the hope is that you will see the
interaction between one of these whims of
which there must be an
incredibly large number, uh,
with something this has so far failed.
Uh,
so there is no direct evidence from wimps.
the other hope I should say is that
every time you build a bigger collider,
you make new kinds of subatomic particles
and that they'll eventually make
something that looks
like it could be a wimp.
And that hasn't been
happened either. Uh, so, uh,
no detections yet,
no direct,
uh,
detections,
with considerable efforts,
you know,
this is going to turn out to be
90% of the mass in the universe.
So you would like to detect it because if
you do, they'll give you a Nobel prize.
Uh, all right, that's one hypothesis.
There's another hypothesis.
So here's hypothesis number two.
It's just,
you know,
dark chunks of something that doesn't
glow ordinary matter, uh, chunks.
Oh yes, yes, yes. All of that.
We don't know what it is.
And so nothing has yet been ruled out.
What happens is that they, you know, they
continued to conduct these experiments.
So you can rule out wimps with certain
kinds of characteristics because you
would have detected them.
Similarly,
you can rule out some of these
other things with certain
characteristics because
you would have noticed they were there.
Uh,
but both of these hypotheses are
still more or less viable, uh,
chunks of ordinary matter,
uh, that just don't glow,
that don't emit light.
Now there's some limitations,
can't they?
These chunks can't be too small
because if what you've got
are, are tiny, you know,
micron size particles,
uh, we call that dust. Uh,
and it basically, that's what it
is. It would just be dust. Uh,
the problem with dust is dust in large
quantities is opaque and you can't see
through it and therefore you
would know it was there, uh,
because it obscures the
light of things behind it.
And indeed we see cosmic
dust this way all the time.
It's just there isn't nearly enough
of it to account for any substantial
fraction of the dark
matter. So dust, uh, would,
uh, be observed because it, uh,
by obscuring light.
And it also tends to glow
in the infrared.
Uh, and so we know that
dust exists, but we can fit,
we can count how much of it there is
because it obscures light and it makes its
presence known in other ways.
It's also true that these chunks of
ordinary matter can't be too big.
They can't be the size of whole galaxies
or even a substantial fraction of a
galaxy. You can take all your dark matter
and put it into one lump per galaxy,
or even a hundred lumps per galaxy.
Because if they were very large masses,
uh, you'd see it because it
would, uh, it would disrupt,
uh,
the orbits of stars around the galaxy.
So if there was some
huge unknown, uh, mass,
you'd see things orbiting around
it. And in fact, we do, uh,
we see the supermassive black holes
in the centers of galaxies and we know
they're there cause we see stars
orbiting around them. Uh, just like, uh,
the problem on, on, on the last midterm,
uh, and so it can't be too small.
It can't be too big.
Uh,
but you could perhaps have
sort of a bunch of star mast,
so you could have,
sorry to have a bunch of star mast,
uh,
or planet mass dark things in a,
it would have to be for various
technical reasons that I won't go into.
It has to be in the
outer parts of galaxies,
in the Halos of galaxies.
So that in principle is possible.
We wouldn't have any direct
way of detecting them.
These things are called
a massive astrophysical,
uh,
compact halo object.
Yeah.
Some people get it a massive,
because they have to carry mass
astrophysical cause they're not particles
compact. Because if they
were big you, you know,
they block light and you'd see them halo
because that's the part of the galaxy
there in a, these are machos. Right.
And so the alternative to whips
his machos. Uh, and so, uh,
the alternative explanation is that
90% of the university's Machos, uh,
there have,
there's been a very clever experiment
carried out to try and find these things.
Uh, here's how you do it. You
do it with gravitational lenses,
Lansing macho searches.
Remember Gravitational lensing.
This is this business
that mass bends light. Uh,
so here you are, you're looking
at some star, and in between UN,
the star is a macho of some kind.
So here's the macho.
You can't see the macho, but
presence of the Macho, uh,
changes the direction of the light.
So it comes into you like this,
and it basically acts like a lens.
And in particular,
the way it acts,
like the lens in the case
of machos lending stars,
uh,
is it makes it brighter,
makes the star brighter.
Uh,
now in order for this to work, the
alignment has to be essentially perfect.
All of these objects are moving around,
you know,
they're orbiting the galaxy and stuff.
So the alignment,
uh,
hold for a few weeks typically.
So what you'll see is you'll see this
star become much brighter and it can
really become much brighter.
We're talking tens to hundreds of times
brighter than it would ordinarily was.
This lasts for a few weeks in, then it
goes away. These have been observed.
These Lenzing events have been observed,
planting event observed.
Uh,
but there are too few of them.
to explain the dark matter.
Now,
there are still ways out.
Let's see if you have
particularly low mass macho.
So things the mass,
supposing the whole universe is filled
with things about the massive earth. Uh,
those won't cause,
uh,
Tho those cause a lensing events
that might be too small to see.
Alternatively,
supposing you have things that are many
thousands of times the mass of a star,
uh, but not big enough to totally
disrupt a galactic whore pit. Uh,
then there are much, many fewer of
them for a given amount of mass and,
and there aren't enough macho events
that you would have expected to see and
he's substantial number of them.
So there's still a way around the result
of these experiments if you want to
believe in machos. Uh, but it's
getting very tough. Uh, so, uh,
so no macho,
no wimps detected so far.
No Machos
uh,
you could still postulate kinds of wimps
and kinds of machos that might explain
the dark matter. Uh, but it's getting
kind of tough. Most people I think, uh,
believe in, in, in wimps.
Most people tend to believe in this.
Uh,
but as far as I can tell,
uh,
that's because the particle physicists
keep coming up with new candidate wimps
that might exist, but we haven't
quite been able to see so far. Uh,
uh, and so there's, uh,
a theoretical basis for the
existence of these things.
Whereas with these machos if you
ask the astronomers, well, fine,
so you want to have 90%
of the be in little earth,
like things just floating around
with no star. How did they,
how did that happen?
How did these come into being a,
we really have no answer at all for that.
So there's no theoretical
basis for any of the,
of the still allowed categories
of machos. Uh, and so,
uh, at the moment people tend
to believe wimps over machos,
although there is no direct
evidence for either. Yes.
Yeah.
The Universe is made of little
riff like objects and a,
wouldn't that mean 90% of the
universe was made of metal?
Oh, uh, earth, earth, Sa Earth
mass objects is what I meant.
I don't care what it's made out
of. Uh, yeah, maybe they're,
maybe they're a little earths.
Earth sized balls of hydrogen. Ah,
that would be fine too. Uh,
except how do you get them, uh,
we know something about how balls
of, of, of, of hydrogen fault,
what form and what they become. They
turn into stars. Uh, this is well known.
Uh, and one of the popular
kinds of machos was just very,
very dim stars. And this
is one of the things, uh,
that this space telescope
helped to rule out, uh,
because it can see really faint
objects and they weren't there. Uh,
and so no wimps, no machos. Uh,
and um, uh, and so we
don't know what's going on.
That was a digression.
Uh,
and what I digressed
from was the fact that,
uh,
this galaxy that we had measured
the mass of turned out to be,
uh,
two times 10 to the 11 solar masses or
around four times 10 to the 41 kilograms.
If you have these things,
uh,
one such galaxy,
every,
I dunno,
two mega parsecs or so what,
uh, the density of the universe. Remember,
that's where we started of the universe.
So now let's finish this
calculation. Uh, let's see. Uh,
the density is equal to mass over volume,
four times 10 to the 41,
uh,
from observing these orbits. Uh, and uh,
the volume down here is going to
be two mega parsecs cubed. Uh,
that's two times 10 to
the six times to uh,
sorry, times three times 10
to the 16. That's one. Parsec.
Uh,
so this is six times 10 to the 22.
I want to cubit six cube six times
six is 36 times another six is 200.
So that's 200 times 10 to the
66 or two times 10 to the 68.
So then the density of the universe,
four times 10 to the 41 over,
uh,
two times 10 to the 68,
that's equal to two times 10 to the
minus 27 kilograms per meter cubed.
Uh,
and in that a real
critical can be calculated.
Turns out to be,
uh,
as you'll discover on the problem set
six times 10 to the minus 27 in these
universe, in these units, uh,
row overrode critical is
equal to about one third.
So if you buy that,
the universe is going to
keep expanding because Omega,
uh, the ratio of the, uh, density
to the critical densities,
only about a third of,
but the problem is we've got all this
dark matter around and what we're doing is
we're adding up galaxies.
How do you know that there isn't a whole
bunch of dark matter where there aren't
galaxies and where there's
nothing to see orbiting around it.
You have no idea what this stuff is. And
indeed, most of the wimp kinds of ideas,
uh, sort of postulate some kind of dark
matter that kind of pervades the universe
until you'd expect there to be somewhat
more of it than you can see in any given
galaxy. Uh, well, somewhat
more than a third, uh,
get you into dangerous
territory. Uh, namely near one a,
which is the thing we're trying to
distinguish whether this number is greater
than one or not.
And so you need a new approach.
This isn't going to get you the answer.
And so, uh, there is a different approach,
uh,
and fats,
what we'll talk about a next time and
that will finally bring us up to frontiers
and controversies in the 21st century.